yo guys so today i have something
special for you we are going to be
reading negative steam reviews for eldon
ring now as most of you probably know
eldon ring has gone completely
mainstream the player base for elden
ring is much higher than all the prior
from software games which is fantastic
for the game i'm very proud of from
software but what comes with that is a
lot of negativity once you reach new
heights like this haters just come out
of the woodwork it's what they do they
can't see something be successful so
they have to [ __ ] on it which you know
shows a lot about a person so let's read
what they have to say the story is
easily missable as the exposition dump
character only appears at certain graces
and only if you notice the talk to her
button i believe this person is
referring to melana who very early on in
the game just automatically appears when
you rest at a side of grace so what
you're saying already doesn't make sense
i normally don't have an issue with the
story in these games as the environment
and item descriptions do the telling but
not knowing why i need to become the
elden lord or how the world got the way
it did has kind of sat my motivation
which consisted of exploring and finding
a new thing it is an open world game so
that's the entire point from what i can
tell it's the same thing as dark souls
with fire being integral big trees and
really boring naming convention elder
everything starts with a [ __ ] m
seriously we have america moog moguin
melania melena mikola miscellant muriel
and runes instead of souls now i can
half agree with you that the names are
really confusing but if you look into
the lore of the game there's a point to
it all of these demi-god and periods are
completely full of themselves and don't
really want to stray too far from the
tree and once you get used to it it's
really not hard to remember the names
and when you say runes instead of souls
this is not dark souls this is elden
ring it's a completely different game
you can call it souls if you want just
like i did in my entire playthrough just
cause that's what i'm used to saying but
that's kind of a weird gripe bad game
has almost 100 hours on record but bad
game right i've never hated anything so
much 27 hours it's not really that much
for this game sounds like you have some
anger issues that you need to work on
and yeah this game can be extremely
frustrating like that's how these games
work but leaving a negative review on it
like come on you put plenty of time into
the game calm down it's a video game
this game has to be the worst game i've
ever played since owning my pc save your
money there's plenty of games exactly
the same for a lot cheaper the graphics
are crap the gameplay is awful the
enemies are shocking they're shocking
can't even get into multiplayer like
fair enough if you're made up over this
game i have no idea what that means
think it's the best about but don't kid
yourself these sentences are really
coming together otherwise developers
won't put much effort into making it
better yeah there's clearly very little
effort put into this game like 200 hours
into this game for me so far and i still
haven't found everything in the game yet
that's already a ton of content whether
you like it or not but yeah there's no
effort put into it clearly this guy also
has one hour so this guy's calling out a
lack of effort when he walked out of the
starting area and died to the tree
sentinel 15 times in a row and quit and
what what a nerd dude i hate this game
says with 94 hours in the game like come
on man i feel like this is just a joke
but i mean bro how do you play something
that much when you hate it and hey maybe
you're into suffering maybe that's
that's your thing all the power to you
dude don't see what all the hype was
about if you don't like dark souls don't
get this it's definitely not at all like
skyrim or even remotely similar in any
way like some people say it is this game
is designed to torture players like dark
souls you will just constantly get
killed by anything and everything a lot
this guy's just speaking facts so far
probably wouldn't be so bad if the
controls didn't feel like you had a 200
pound free weight strapped to your head
so i like all the dark souls games i
played all of them for thousands of
hours they're my favorite games of all
time and i love elden ring i think it's
better than all of them that's just me
though can't be the same for everybody
when he says it's not like skyrim it's
because it's not it's an open world game
like skyrim but that's pretty much it
skyrim gives you a quest log gives you
all this hand-holdy stuff to progress
you through the game a lot of people
really prefer that i don't like being
told what to do which is why i like
elden rings so much i think what eldon
ring has shown in the gaming community
is that some people cannot handle
freedom in a video game if they aren't
told where to go exactly they don't know
what to do where exploration and just
free roam to do whatever you want is the
entire point of elden ring you can
immerse yourself in the content and the
story as much as you want but it's
really up to you to go find it that's
not a bad thing when he says the game is
designed to torture players he's not
wrong it's designed to torture players
who won't make the necessary changes to
progress the definition of insanity is
repeating the same thing over and over
again and expecting a different result
just like with elden ring you have to go
make the proper changes you have to go
to do the proper leveling you have to
get good when people say get good they
aren't kidding get better at the game
and then it won't be so torturous
anymore that's kind of how life works my
guy said it feels like there's a 200
pound free weight attached to you with
the movement in this game yeah it's not
apex legends where slightly sprinting
and pressing crouch will glide you all
the way down a hill in rapidly changing
movements just like all the dark souls
games your inputs matter your decisions
that you make in this game even down to
just pressing a button matters so when
you spam the roll button or spam the
attack button it's gonna input that so
you have to be careful sorry i beat a
boss and some stupid troll makes it to
where i can't hit the grace after i'm
done 220 hours in and i'm done debs were
not loved as children no it's very
apparent that miyazaki was never loved
as a child i completely agree with that
he loves torturing people can't be loved
as a kid i think he's referring to when
somebody puts a message near a grace so
people do this to troll it's a very
common thing but all you have to do is
is read you press sideways on the d-pad
and it will go from the option of
reading the message to resting at the
grace it's not hard i'm sorry that
bothered you so much though amazing game
but melania no i will say that melania
has some really janky mechanics that
make that boss fight a struggle but it's
such a beautiful fight you can dodge
that crazy attack that this guy's
probably referring to takes a lot of
practice takes a lot of time difficult
boss i think it's fair though just my
opinion sorry that bothered you with 94
hours in the game man gank fights are
not good boss design over and over and
over again see 32 hours in could he be a
godskin duo there maybe that'd be really
fast get the god skin duo actually yeah
there's a good amount of duo boss fights
in this game hey i think this should be
a universal rule where you feel like
you're getting ganked it is definitely
100 okay even the try-hard rune level
one guys that say you can never use a
summon in a gank fight i think it's
universally okay to use a summon in my
opinion i think it's universally okay to
use a summon whenever you want because
it's your game it's your decisions and
somebody else's playthrough does not
affect your playthrough my guy but gank
fights use a summon way easier honestly
it's too difficult to get past any boss
your level makes no difference only
people who really enjoy these different
games will have fun dude this is not
fortnite dude this is not call of duty
my guy like nobody's gonna enjoy this
because it's hard bro like i one pump
this boss in the face dude and then he
slapped me with a sword my guy don't buy
it if looking for a more enjoyable
realistically progressive game i mean if
you're playing this game you're not
gonna be touching very much grass so
that is not very progressive [ __ ]
horrendous two bosses are full rng and
this game makes me want to shove my fist
i can't read the rest of that i don't
think youtube's gonna like me saying
that calm down you're a freak 277 hours
in the game
wow you have some problems dude get some
help too hard too big too long
that's what she said three and a half
hours in died to the tree sentinel can't
change my mind you got triggered and
you're bad it is a really stunningly
beautiful game with amazing visuals and
good fighting styles and is very well
laid out okay but negative review
however but for me the game just kind of
throws you into the world and says
figure it out facts i love that and
without watching some kind of beginner's
guide you are kinda just lost with no
idea what to do personally i'm going to
refund it and i can see why others love
the crap out of it but it just isn't for
me honestly dude bare enough however i
think a lot of people missed this but
i'm going to show you what you can do
about this so we've all been here right
this is where we start the game our
journey in eldon ring and i cannot tell
you how many people i have seen
completely missed the tutorial like
they'll just run straight to the door
they're ready to go baby and then they
find out they're not ready but yeah they
missed this tutorial even though there's
a glowing man in a chair right next to
you and a universal message on the
ground that says the cave of knowledge
lies below cave of knowledge what could
that what could that mean nothing i need
i'm going baby let's go yeah you go down
into this area and it will give you
detailed descriptions of how to do
everything pretty much everything all of
the necessities so while it may feel
like they just throw you out into the
world of elden ring and say good luck
have fun or try to have fun they do give
you the knowledge they do they just
don't hand feed it to you they expect
you to be smarter than that or a better
way to put that is they respect you as a
player to like figure it out on your own
that's gonna do it for this video
everybody i really appreciate you
watching if you enjoyed it leave a like
subscribe leave a comment down below
what you want to see next we could do we
could go to reddit reddit's way harsher
than steam reviews to be honest maybe
even tick tock comments like oh my god
they are tick tock is
stupid but anyway let me know peace and
love have a great day